nos preguntan cuál de las siguientes
opciones describe un bien que tiene
mayor elasticidad en la demanda pausa en
el vídeo y traten de encontrar la
respuesta la primera opción dice un bien
de lujo que tiene muchos sustitutos ya
mencionamos que cuando algo tiene muchos
sustitutos la cantidad demandada se
vuelve muy sensible al precio y el hecho
de que esté bien sea un bien de lujo no
es algo que las personas necesiten y
esto generalmente hace que la cantidad
sea más sensible al precio por lo que es
más elástico esto luce como un buen
candidato pero veamos las otras opciones
un bien necesario con pocos sustitutos
esto es lo opuesto a la opción anterior
un bien necesario es inelástico o menos
elástico y además si tiene pocos
sustitutos
si esto sufre un cambio de precio
entonces las personas no tendrán más
remedio que comprarlo porque es una
necesidad y no pueden sustituirlo con
otra cosa lo que también lo hace en
elástico recuerden que nos preguntan por
el bien que tiene la mayor elasticidad
en la demanda así que descartamos esta
opción
un bien de amplia definición como comida
acabamos de hablar de esto
si hablamos de comida y hay un cambio de
precio en la comida todos necesitamos
comer la cantidad demandada no va a
cambiar demasiado esto es muy inelástica
la descartamos bienes que componen una
pequeña proporción de nuestro
presupuesto esto nos recuerda el ejemplo
de la goma de mascar si la goma de
mascar pasa de costar 25 centavos a 30
centavos no nos importará demasiado en
comparación con el cambio en el precio
de un auto que pasa de 250 mil pesos a
300 mil pesos por lo que en las cosas
pequeñas no nos importa mucho que cambie
su precio y claro si no nos importa el
cambio de precio esto implicará
inelasticidad por lo que no tiene la
mayor elasticidad en la demanda bienes
que tienen que comprarse en un corto
periodo de tiempo un ejemplo de esto es
que esté lloviendo y las personas
necesiten un paraguas durante los
próximos cinco o diez minutos esto no es
necesariamente sensible al precio por lo
que esto es inelástico por lo que
también descartamos esta opción
si aquí tuviéramos un periodo de tiempo
largo entonces las personas podrían
comprar algún sustituto por lo que las
cosas podrían volverse más elásticas y
más sensibles al precio así que
confirmamos que la opción correcta es el
escenario de la opción nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo